der wohl größte vermisstenfall der welt
wo ist maddie mccann das kleine
englische mädchen das im urlaub in
portugal vor jahren spurlos verschwunden
ist unser bild reporter kai feldhaus hat
recherchiert seit jahren ja es ist sein
größter fall so heißt auch die doku
reihe mein größter fall erkennt alle
relevanten spuren und es soll neue
erkenntnisse geben bevor wir mit ihm
sprechen ein ausschnitt aus seiner
großen dokumentation heute abend
es gibt glaube ich keinen fall der
weltweit solche schlagzeilen machen seit
dem dritten mai 2007 ist sie einfach
verschwunden aus dieser ferienanlage an
der portugiesischen algarve alle kennen
die geschichte
[Musik]
die staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig sagt
es gibt einen deutschen vorbestraften
kinderschänder der metal merc entführt
und ermordet
hauptverdächtiger ist der 43 jährige
christian b der derzeit in haft sitzt in
salou amaral hat die ermittlungen im
fall maddie mccann von anfang an geführt
nach seinem verständnis sind kate und
gerry mccann diejenigen die das
verschwinden ihrer tochter verursacht
haben ich habe bis heute keine zweifel
dass eine entführung dort nur simuliert
wurde es gibt mehrere anzeichen dafür
ein fenster von denen niemand sicher
sagen konnte ob es offen oder
geschlossen war trotzdem hat man uns
erzählt dass der angeblichen führe dort
hinein und wieder hinaus geklettert ist
es gab fingerabdrücke der mutter des
kindes die zeigen dass sie das fenster
geöffnet hat es waren die einzigen die
gefunden dass gonzalo amaral jetzt ganz
klar sagt christian b das ist nun so ein
blog das ist der ideale verdächtige den
sie immer gesucht haben und der hat
erfüllt jetzt mal diese rolle das halte
ich für extrem wertvoll
was passiert wenn ein kind verschwindet
um das zu verstehen habe ich mich mit
dem experten axel petermann verabredet
hätte er vielleicht die eltern als
erstes genauer unter die lupe genommen
lebt denkt fuchs war immer das schiff
das die familie ein harter geborgenheit
ist der zuneigung füreinander da sein
aber der alltag zeigt uns doch genau das
gegenteil und deswegen muss man eine
solche möglichkeit denken man muss sich
sehr genau mit den spuren des
verschwindens auseinandersetzung um dann
zu sagen ich bin wichtig oder aber ich
muss eine andere version auflegt ich
treffe jetzt in hamburg den anwalt von
christian brückner friedrich fällt schon
denen werde ich jetzt mal dazu befragen
wie geht es ihnen denn im gefängnis das
ist eine blöde frage er sitzt für eine
straftat mehrere jahre in hart von der
er behauptet diese nicht begangen zu
haben und es an der weltweiten foto
anders kampagne ausgesetzt also wie soll
es weitergehen die große frage die im
raum stehen wer ist verantwortlich für
das verschwinden von madeleine mccann
wenn man glaubt jetzt nicht alle
meinungen gehört dank kommt christian
rund um die ecke und erzählt uns selbst
was wir über diesen fall denken wir über
die skandalöse vorverurteilung in seiner
in seinem fall denkt und safa hört
einfach nicht auf
bizarre wendung und wollten zu nehmen
jetzt ist er bei uns im studio kai
feldhaus kai und du hast am ende gesagt
dieser fall hört einfach nicht auf immer
wieder neue wendungen und in der tat es
gibt eine neue englische
dokumentation die sagte die ermittlungen
gegen den verdächtigen christian
brückner ständen unmittelbar vor dem aus
du hast recherchiert dem widersprechen
aber die deutschen ermittler das ist
richtig thomas mann muss beim fall
maddie mccann wissen dass er 14 jahren
ständig neue nachrichten auf ploppen
ständig gibt es irgendwelche
informationen gerade in england wird das
thema ja fast täglich gespielt da muss
man dann versuchen sauber zu trennen was
ist jetzt einfach noch mal wieder
gekreuzt worden was ist noch mal wieder
ausgegraben worden was ist wirklich
relevant und was nicht in diesem falle
sind wir doch sehr aufmerksam geworden
weil das christian brückner ein alibi
für den tatabend haben könnte dass statt
bisher nie zur diskussion ich habe jetzt
mal entsprechend nach gefühl an der
dokumentation behauptet genau richtig
dass das behaupten die engländer die
sagen an dem tatabend sei er 30 minuten
entfernt vom tatort gewesen ich habe
jetzt noch mal unsere unterlagen
geschaut hab ein bisschen telefoniert
aber auch mit der staatsanwaltschaft
gesprochen sie widersprechen dem ganz
klar die sagen wir wissen nichts von
einem alibi der weder der beschuldigte
noch sein anwalt haben sich eingelassen
sind bisher nicht befragt worden würden
aber auch entsprechend nichts sagen und
solange die sagen wir wissen nichts von
einem alibi
würde ich davon wenn ich darauf jetzt
mal nicht so viel geben eines der wenig
bekannten indizien ist ja dass das handy
von christian brückner am zum
tatzeitpunkt eingeloggt war in der
region womé die auch verschwunden ist
was kannst du uns dazu sagen du sagst
ganz richtig lisa das handy von
christian brückner war zur tatzeit am
tatort ein gelockt heißt die erstmal gar
nichts mehr das bedeutet dass das handy
das er in diesen zu dieser zeit wohl
besaß dort eingeloggt war die
staatsanwaltschaft sagt aber auch ganz
klar wir haben nie was anderes behauptet
wir haben nie gesagt er war am tatort
wir sagen sein handy war dort und wir
suchen noch händeringend und fieberhaft
den menschen die person mit der er
telefoniert hat die hat sich nämlich bis
heute nicht gemeldet da gibt es eine
nummer aber das war eine prepaid-karte
sie wissen nicht wem diese nummer
zugeordnet war und solange das nicht
geklärt ist solange diese personen nicht
sagt ich habe dort mit christian
brückner telefoniert wir halten uns ein
handy da und diese doku es gibt glaube
ich nach meinem kenntnisstand wird nun
behaupten dass jemand anderer dieses
handy bei sich geführt habe an diesem
abend warum das so ist das ist mir nicht
klar ich habe auch mit leuten gesprochen
die christian brückner damals gut
kannten gestern die sagen der hat das
handy niemals aus der hand gegeben also
da bin ich sehr gespannt was ist dann
mit diesem handy noch auf sich haben
auch was die liebe betrifft würde man
sich ja denken na ja wenn ich eine alibi
gehabt dann sage ich das ja als erstes
mal das ist richtig also zunächst mal
muss man sagen die staatsanwaltschaft
hat ihn noch nicht befragt die haben ja
immer gesagt ganz am ende der
ermittlungen werden wir ihnen dazu
befragen sein anwalt friedrich
wirtschaft hat aber bereits gesagt
braucht könnt euch sparen den weg er
wird dazu nicht sagen es wird keine
einlassung machen aber richtig ist
natürlich dass in dem moment wo er
belegen kann dass er ein alibi hat dass
er bei jemandem war der das bezeugen
kann kann man die ermittlungen
einstellen dass er das nicht tut das
deutet schon darauf hin dass dieses
alibi vielleicht nicht so ganz so
wasserdicht ist wie die engländer uns
glauben machen es ist er 14 jahre her
die ganze geschichte und wie sicher ist
überhaupt ein alibi von 14 jahren wenn
man mich fragen würde wo warst du an dem
bestimmten tag vor 14 jahren das hast du
da gemacht es war schwierig zu
beantworten oder nach meinem
kenntnisstand machen die jetzt ein
bisschen viel wind mit dieser englischen
tv doku es gibt tatsächlich eine person
eine damalige freundin von christian
brückner die sagt ich habe in dem
besagten zeitraum sehr viel zeit mit ihm
verbracht fast jeden abend ob aber genau
dieser abend nämlich der dritte mai 2007
was war das für ein wochentag wer weiß
das schon noch ob der dabei war das kann
sie eben nicht sagen und ich glaube dass
die englischen kollegen diese person
jetzt so sehr aufblasen zu einem alibi
um natürlich auch ein bisschen werbung
für ihren film dazu machen aber am ende
kennt die staatsanwaltschaft diese
person schon die wurde schon lange
vernommen und wird eben nicht als ein
wasserdichtes alibi eingestuft und warum
lässt sich die deutsche
staatsanwaltschaft ist soviel zeit
christian brückner persönlich zu
befragen weil sie zeit hat sie wissen wo
er ist in der jva oldenburg besitzt er
ein und zwar noch für mindestens sechs
jahre
das heißt man wirklich ein anderer
verbrechen richtig genau es wegen einer
vergewaltigung verurteilt worden dort
sitzt er einen deshalb ist zu sieben
jahren verurteilt worden im letzten jahr
da wurde das rechtskräftig sie wissen
immer wo er ist wenn sie ihn befragen
wollen können sie hinfallen muss es tun
er geht ihnen nicht mehr von der fahne
das wäre anders wenn er jetzt noch
draußen wäre dann müsste man darüber
reden ob möglicherweise einen aber
stetig staatsanwaltschaft kein ich
trotzdem auch unter druck das war ja
sehr aufsehen der regel vor anderthalb
jahren rausgegangen sind mit der
mitteilung wir halten ihn für den
verdächtigen und wir gehen davon aus
dass maddie tot ist ein schock nachricht
natürlich für die eltern die nach wie
vor glauben hoffen dass ihr kind lebt
also die staatsanwaltschaft hat sich
schon sehr weit aus dem fenster gehängt
und jetzt sind anderthalb jahre
vergangen und man hat das gefühl es
kommt nicht so richtig was vom fleck ich
habe nicht das gefühl dass die sonne
deutlich unter druck stehen ich habe
gestern mit mit dem ermittelnden
staatsanwalt christian wolters gemailt
er hat mir auch im persönlichen gespräch
schon gesagt wir wollen das gründlich
machen die eltern sind die allerersten
die die wir informieren wenn wir
stichfeste beweise haben die haben wir
aber nicht das sagt ja öffentlich wir
wollen aus ermitteln was wir haben und
wenn wir damit fertig sind dann
entscheiden wir ob der anklage erheben
oder nicht wir reden hier von
ermittlungen drei ländern in deutschland
in england in portugal als auch von drei
verschiedenen behörden wir reden von
einer pandemie in der das alles passiert
das heißt reisen ist nicht so einfach
wie lassen sich die zeit die sie haben
und wenn sie wirklich dingfest sind und
sagen wir klagen an dann werden dass man
den eltern als erster erfahren aber ich
habe nicht das gefühl dass sie über
hansi unter druck stehen heute abend
also die große doku mein größter fall
das verschwinden von maddie mccann auch
angesichts der neuen entwicklung warum
sollte man heute abend unbedingt ein
schlag ich glaube dass unsere doku die
bisher einzige ist und ich glaube das
wird auch bestand haben wenn die
engländer dann gesendet haben in der
tatsächlich alle menschen die relevant
sind für den fall zu wort kommen unter
anderem auch belastungszeugen die bisher
nicht öffentlich aufgetreten sind die
das ganze ins rollen gebracht haben die
sprechen da denen wir darum gegeben das
heißt wir versuchen nicht irgendwelche
theorien zu konstruieren wie es gewesen
sein könnte sondern versuchen
herauszufinden wer ist dieser mann der
verdächtigt wird und warum könnte es
tatsächlich gewesen seien und warum
vielleicht auch nicht